IN ALL CASES, THE MESSAGE COULD
NOT BE CLEARER, DEMOCRATS ARE ON
THE SIDE OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
THEY ARE NOT EVEN PRETENDING
ANYMORE.
THE ANCHOR WHO JUST WROTE A
BOOK, CALLED "STRANGER."
THE CHALLENGE OF THE LATINO
IMMIGRANT, JOINING US NOW.
>> GOOD TO BE JOINING YOU,
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU SO MUCH,
CONGRATULATIONS ON THE BOOK.
PARTLY ABOUT WHAT AMERICAN
POLICIES ARE TO BE, WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT IT SHOULD BE
IN THE SHOW.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT A TWEET
YOU SENT OUT TO THAT I WAS
AMAZED BY, IN SPANISH, BUT
I GOT MY VOTER CREDENTIAL TO
VOTE FOR THE UNITED STATES IN
THE ELECTION IN MEXICO ON
JULY 1ST.
NOW I HAVE TO REGISTER AND WAIT
FOR MY BALLOT BY MAIL, AND
EXPENSIVE AND COMPLICATED
PROCESS, BUT YOU HAVE TO DO IT.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE AN AMERICAN?
>> I AM MEXICAN AND I AM
AMERICAN, THAT IS COMPLETELY
LEGAL.
I WISH THAT I COULD GIVE YOU AN
EXPLANATION ON MY IDENTITY,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I AM.
I WAS BORN IN MEXICO AND BEGAN A
U.S. CITIZEN.
I HAVE THE CHANCE TO DO THAT.
I FEEL VERY PROUD OF BEING FROM
MEXICO IN THE UNITED STATES.
SPEND THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
BEING FROM MEXICO, I AGREE WITH
THAT COMPLETELY.
WHAT IS WRONG IS THAT YOU TOOK
THE FOLLOWING OATH, THIS WAS A
PLEDGE AND WHO SAID THEY SWORE
ABSOLUTELY TO RENOUNCE ALL
ALLEGIANCE TO ANY FOREIGN STATE
YOU HAVE EVER BEEN A CITIZEN OF
PAID YOU TOOK THAT OATH, BUT TO
YOU ARE VOTING IN A FOREIGN
ELECTION?
WHY ARE YOU DOING THAT?
>> I AM VOTING IN MEXICO AND
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
WRONG.
SOME COUNTRIES ALLOW THAT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHY YOU HAVE
A U.S. PASSPORT.
I AM NOT THE ONLY ONE AND I
THINK THAT I CAN PARTICIPATE
FULLY IN THE U.S. AND I CAN DO
EXACTLY THE SAME THING IN MEXICO
EXACTLY THE SAME THING IN MEXIC
MEXICO.
MEXICAN AMERICANS, THAT IS
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: I THINK A LOT OF
THE VIEWERS MAY NOT TO KNOW THAT
YOU CAN VOTE IN A FOREIGN
ELECTION WHEN, BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO SHOW I.D. --
>> NOW THEY KNOW.
AND IT IS HAPPENING IN EUROPE
AND IN MEXICO, NOT ONLY MEXICO
AND THE U.S.
MEXICO IS NOT INVADING THE U.S.,
AND WE ARE NOT AT WAR.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT
INVADING THE UNITED STATES, AND
HE GETS, MEXICAN CITIZENS LIVE
IN THIS COUNTRY, VOTE IN MEXICAN
ELECTIONS AND THEN WRITE BOOKS
TELLING AMERICANS LIKE ME HOW WE
SHOULD RUN OUR GOVERNMENT WHEN
YOU CLEARLY HAVE NOT RENOUNCED
YOUR LOYALTY TO A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENT.
WHY SHOULD I TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY?
>> I HAPPEN TO BE A U.S.
CITIZEN.
AND SOMETIMES AND THAT IS THE
TITLE OF THE BOOK I DO FEEL LIKE
"A STRANGER."
BECAUSE IT SEEMS LIKE AS YOU
POINTED OUT THAT FOR MANY
AMERICANS I AM NOT AMERICAN
ENOUGH.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE VOTING IN A
FOREIGN ELECTION.
HOLD ON, HOLD ON.
IT IS NOT ABOUT MEXICO, IT COULD
BE ANY COUNTRY.
WHY SHOULD I TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY
AS AN AMERICAN IF YOU ARE STILL
TIED TO A COUNTRY DESPITE THE
OATH YOU TOOK, APPARENTLY
DISINGENUOUS LEAD TO RENOUNCE
YOUR TIES TO THE COUNTRY?
YOU ARE WEIGHING IN ON A FOREIGN
ELECTION.
>> JUST BECAUSE OF MY ARGUMENTS
AND JUST BECAUSE I AM A U.S.
CITIZEN AS YOU ARE.
SO I CANNOT COMPLAIN.
AND THINGS I CANNOT COMPLAIN
ABOUT DONALD TRUMP BEING THE
MOST ANTI-IMMIGRANT PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE, YOU CAN
COMPLAIN ALL YOU WANT TO.
>> SIMPLY BECAUSE I CAME HERE
AND I AM --
>> Tucker: I AM ASKING WHY I
SHOULD TAKE YOU SERIOUSLY?
LET'S ASK ABOUT THE STORY WE
JUST PLAYED.
HERE YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO HAS
BEEN CHARGED BY AUTHORITIES WITH
HOMICIDE AND FLEEING THE SCENE
OF A HOMICIDE.
AND FEDERAL AUTHORITIES SAY THAT
THIS GUY IS IN THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY, NOBODY DISPUTES THAT
IN THE CITY OF DENVER DECIDES TO
LET HIM GO ON A VERY SMALL BOND,
WHY WANTED TO THEY CALLED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM
ENFORCING FEDERAL LAW?
>> THE WAY THAT YOU PRESENT THIS
STORY I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU WOULD
WANT TO BE STATE MEDIA, TUCKER,
BECAUSE YOU ARE CRIMINALIZING
ALL IMMIGRANTS.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT
CRIMINALIZING ANYBODY.
>> YOU ARE DOING EXACTLY WHAT
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING.
>> Tucker: SPARE ME YOUR
VIEWPOINT.
I'M ASKING YOU A QUESTION.
>> OKAY, THIS IS THE ARGUMENT.
THE ARGUMENT IS THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANTS, YOU HAVE
HEARD THIS ARGUMENT.
THE VAST MAJORITY ARE NOT
CRIMINALS.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> AND TODAY ARE LESS LIKELY TO
BE CRIMINALS AND BEHIND BARS.
>> Tucker: THE SECOND POINT IS
NOT TRUE.
I AGREE, MOST IMMIGRANTS ARE
GREAT PEOPLE.
>> EVERY IMMIGRANT ALL THE TIME.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT TRYING TO
CRIMINALIZE ANYBODY.
I'M JUST NOTING THAT THIS GUY
HAS BEEN CHARGED IN OUR COUNTRY
WITH HOMICIDE AND TO THE
AUTHORITIES IN DENVER FOR
POLITICAL REASONS FROM PEOPLE
LIKE YOU HAVE DECIDED THAT THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO TURN HIM OVER
TO THE FEDS AND NOW HE WALKS
FREE, WHY SHOULD I BE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT?
>> I WISH THAT I COULD HAVE THAT
INFORMATION.
THE ARGUMENT IS ABOUT TO
SANCTUARY CITIES, THAT'S WHAT
YOU DO NOT WANT?
>> Tucker: I'M SAYING IN THIS
SPECIFIC CASE.
>> NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO DEFEND
THIS.
>> Tucker: BUT THIS GUY, WHY
THIS GUY?
HE IS CHARGED WITH HOMICIDE,
PEOPLE DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT TRUMP BEING MEAN
TO IMMIGRANTS, THEY DO NOT WANT
A GUY CHARGED WITH HOMICIDE
WALKING THE STREET.
>> JUST TO CRIMINALS, ALL
IMMIGRANTS BECAUSE OF ONE PERSON
WOULD BE LIKE IF I HAD CRIMINALS
OF THE WHITE POPULATION JUST
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED IN LAS VEGAS.
>> Tucker: YOU PULL BACK ON
THE WHITE POPULATION.
NOT THAT STUFF OFF.
>> YOU CRITICIZE THE WHOLE
POPULATION OR GROUP SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF ONE PERSON.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE I AGREE
WITH THAT, YOU SHOULD NEVER
ATTACK PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF
THINGS BECAUSE OF OTHER PEOPLE.
I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT ALL
PEOPLE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THIS PERSON
WHO IS PROTECTED BY POLICIES
THAT YOU SUPPORT AND HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR AND THE REST OF US
ARE SUFFERING BECAUSE OF THAT.
SO WHY DON'T YOU TELL ME WHY
DOES A GOOD IDEA TO LET THIS GUY
OUT OF JAIL, MR. NECK TATTOO
CHARGED WITH HOMICIDE AND WHY
SHOULD WE BE HAPPY ABOUT THAT?
THEY COULD HAVE TURNED THEM OVER
AND THEY DID NOT BECAUSE OF
PRESSURE FROM YOU?
>> I'M NOT HERE DEFENDING ANY
CRIMINALS.
BUT I THINK THAT THE ACTIVITY IS
I THINK THAT SOMEBODY HAS TO
DEFEND IMMIGRANTS.
YOU KNOW, I WAS RECENTLY --
>> Tucker: WHO IS GOING TO
DEFEND THE REST OF US?
>> LET ME GIVE YOU ANOTHER
ARGUMENT, LISTENING TO WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN LOS ANGELES AND THE
LOS ANGELES POLICE CHIEF SAID
THE FOLLOWING, THAT THE REPORTS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN THE CITY OF
LATINOS HAS DECLINED, WHY?
BECAUSE OF FEAR.
AND THEN HE SAID THE FOLLOWING
WHICH I THINK IT'S VERY
POWERFUL.
HE SAID IMAGINE A YOUNG WOMAN,
IMAGINE YOUR DAUGHTER, YOUR
SISTER, YOUR MOTHER, NOT
REPORTING A SEXUAL ASSAULT
THEIR FAMILY WILL BE TORN APART.
>> Tucker: THAT IS NOT A REAL
STATISTIC.
BECAUSE IT IS PURELY -- THAT IS
PURELY SPECULATIVE.
A POLITICAL HACK.
HE CANNOT KNOW THAT.
THAT IS NOT SOCIAL SCIENCE.
SORRY, PAL.
>> THERE WERE REPORTS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PRETENDING
WITHIN THE CITY, LATINO
POPULATION, SO THIS IS HAPPENING
POPULATION, SO THIS IS HAPPENIN
HAPPENING.
THIS IS REAL.
>> Tucker: I NEED TO LOOK AT
MY STATISTICS CLASS IN COLLEGE,